what we're going to do in this video is
dig a little bit deeper into our
understanding of multiplication and just
as an example we're going to use four
times seven and some of you might know
what four times seven is but even in
this case I think you might get
something from this video because we're
going to think about how you can break
down a multiplication question into
simpler parts and that's going to be
useful well beyond four times seven it's
going to be useful in your future when
you're tackling more and more
complicated things now there's a couple
of ways that we can visualize four times
seven my favorite way is to visualize it
with angry cats so let's bring on the
angry cats
Yep they're still angry and we can see
that this is a representation of four
times seven we have four rows right over
here
four rows and each of those rows have
seven cats
and so you can see that right over here
each of those rows have seven cats some
people would call this a four by seven
Grid or four by seven array whatever
however you'd want to view it but if
someone were to ask you what's the total
number of cats it would be four rows
times seven columns four times seven now
another way to represent four times
seven is also with a tape diagram you
might see something like this where here
we're visualizing it as seven fours or
you could view it as four plus four plus
four plus four plus four plus four plus
four now that's all well and good and
you can add that up if you like but what
I promised you is that we would figure
out ways to break down things that might
simplify things in the future
well what if you didn't know what four
times seven is but you knew what 4 times
5 is and you knew what 4 times 2 is well
what's interesting is that 7 is 5 plus
2. so what if we tried to First figure
out
this many cats so four rows and five
columns
right over there
and then we tried to figure out
this many cats four rows and two columns
and you can see that it's the exact same
number of cats so one way to think about
it is four times seven is the exact same
thing as four times and I'm going to use
parentheses and that just means to do
that part first is equal to four times
instead of seven I could write that as 5
plus 2 because that's what 7 is so all
this is saying is 4 times 7 is the same
thing as four times five plus two where
you do the five plus two first because
we have those parentheses around it and
five plus two is indeed equal to seven
and we can see that that is equivalent
to the total number of cats that we have
here which we could view as what we just
circled off in this orangish pink color
which would be four rows of five so that
would be equal to four times five
four times five and then to that we can
add
this second group of cat heads or angry
cat heads and that is four rows of two
so that's four times two and we could
put parentheses if we want just to make
it a little bit more readable now why
did I do that well some folks might find
four times five a little bit more
straightforward I could skip count by
five I can go five ten fifteen twenty
also four times two might be a little
bit more straightforward and so it could
be easier to say hey this is just going
to be 4 times 5 which is 20 plus 4 times
2 which is equal to eight and so that is
just going to be equal to
twenty eight and you could have thought
about it the same way down here with
what is sometimes called a tape diagram
we could say all right if I have five
fours
that this Mount right over here that is
the four times the five and then I could
add that to the two fours the four times
the 2 right over here and that's another
way to get to four times seven so the
big picture here is even if you're not
dealing with four times seven even if
you're not dealing with angry cats and
in most of our Lives we we actually try
to avoid angry cats there might be a way
to break down the numbers that you're
multiplying into ones that you might be
more familiar with I'll give you one
more example let's say someone were to
ask you well what is six times nine
pause this video and see if you can
break down break this down in some
useful way
well maybe you know what 6 times 10 is
and you also know what 6 times 1 is so
you could rewrite 9 as
10 minus 1.
well then this would mean that 6 times 9
is the same thing as 6 times 10 minus
one based on exactly what we just did up
here that says that this whole thing is
going to be the same thing as 6 times 10
6 times 10
minus six times one one way to think
about it is I just distributed the six
that's the distributive property right
over there and then six times ten is
equal to 60 and then six times one is
equal to 6 and it might be easier for me
to say hey 16 minus 6 in my head that's
equal to 54. so I know what some of you
are thinking 6 times 9 seems so clean
and now I've involved all of this other
symbolism symbols and I've written down
more numbers but at the end of the day
I'm trying to give you skills for
breaking down problems and including
ways that you might want to do in your
head if you're like hey I'm kind of
foggy and what six times nine is but 6
times 10. hey I know that 60 and 6 times
1 of course that's six well what if I
view this as 6 times 10 minus 1 and then
I could tackle it and get 54. and once
again you might know 6 times 9. you
might know four times seven but in the
future it might be useful for bigger and
bigger numbers to think about how could
I break this down